[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what good morning
it's Thursday we're making our way
through the week you guys and um what
else happens this Thursday is doom and
doom - got some pretty nifty updates
courtesy of Bethesda if you guys haven't
heard they've added a ton of stuff to do
one and doom - some general quality of
life updates they have some add-on
support add-ons can now be downloaded
and played from the main menu and
they're gonna continue to add content
that is a mixture of official doom in
Doom two add-ons as well as some of the
best community episodes and mega wads
released from the original doom game
hell yes as if you thought that was a
lot already there are 60 FPS support
added aspect ratio options added quick
save and load added level select added
weapon carousel play everything massive
like there's a ton of stuff I'm reading
from list right now because it would be
impossible remember I'm some of my head
how many things are at
to this quick weapon select was added
added overall brightness and level
brightness added random sound effects
pitch toggle new split-screen HUD it's a
lot it's a lot it's a lot they've also
changed the health graphics and changed
Wolfenstein secret level and then there
was like a bunch of performance
optimization Oh music yeah
performance optimization some general
fixes and you know kind of tackling some
of the known issues that have been a
part of it
and this update has come to all of the
platform oh yeah every platform has it
today we're playing on switch but it's
also available on PC it's available on
everything that doom and doom 2 is
currently on if you guys do want to see
all of the patch notes we're gonna get
send you the link here so you can take a
look for yourself
that's for you to yeah that's for you
guys that is all that's all the info for
the update and yeah I think we're gonna
go ahead yeah get to the action we
actually turned off the sound effects so
we can jam out to the music yeah we're
gonna need em sound effects oh there it
is already gadem alright so we're gonna
start off playing a little classic doom
and show you guys the 60fps there's
quicksave there's a shortcuts to weapons
now so we'll show it we'll play a few
levels of original doom 2 and then we'll
get into some final doom which has been
added hell yes hurt me plenty ultra
stream for the sake of stream look at
that listen to that
I know it's good it's some good stuff so
yeah we're just gonna check this out
this is one spot - yeah but I was
honestly saying like this is a great
game plans which I think it's also on
mobile and the mobile titles also got
this update
- so very good yeah there it is look at
quick selection that's sweet
easy-peasy although I was having fun
with the chains all right this is where
gear has got their inspiration but yeah
chat thanks for tuning in thanks for
joining us hello everybody everyone with
the warm welcome thank you for joining
us today
hi grandpa bear I see I see I see your
greeting no need to spam oh wow you know
what I played this when it originally
released onto the switch and ps4 and I
had a good time but now it's it's like
perfected the music is back and like it
was a little slower in the original
release which bugged a lot of players me
so much although the music in Doom is
good so memorable I'm just glad they
fixed it whoa I'm getting beat up in the
first level one health one hell magic
pics oh no I don't want they gotta shoot
me is no more health around here I'm
doomed gonna find some some heels
there's some in the last room but
there's also a bad guy Oh see oh please
I came across it there is you imp what a
Brandon welcome back thank you a grumpy
bear hope you're having a good Thursday
though yeah picking it up right in my
opinion with game says always
entertaining watching to you well thank
you yeah okay
this opens the door I think like over
here yeah but there's bad guys but
there's a fighter says do I know any ps4
games that cost nothing because I'm
streaming tuned would be happy to to if
we could tell them some honestly I'm not
sure what's free but if you already have
a membership they always have those ps4
games like that are free every month or
something like that you can download for
free
if you want to oh oh sorry I was gonna
make the little little crosses there
have been fixed because in the Nintendo
released they were little pills instead
of crosses and that's just been patched
back in its article exactly sure why but
there you go
level one but I think a really good deal
is actually like PS now cuz it's like
this price of one like full titled game
but you get like hundreds and hundreds
of games and they're all really good so
any and they even have like goofy games
that probably aren't that great but it's
free they're there and I played them
anyways like the surgeon simulator oh
that's probably the worst game ever but
it's still so funny we used to make
memes about that on Facebook yeah we use
that a lot like even on streaming views
PlayStation now quite a bit we love it
here Adam in the chat says I think this
game has been ported to microwave and
even collects you're just talking about
I play on calculating calculators like
oh shoot iPods like classic iPod with
the click wheel everything everything
them classic iPods you here we are due
to that's running so smoothly says can
you demonstrate the aspect ratio options
can you do that maybe aren't you yeah
noisy start and then there are it's just
blast these fools are up wake your men
oh yeah you know that's new
best gun in doom ever the super shotgun
okay
audiences we're back to the classic we
are baby thank you for tuning the great
thing about you know living in the
future is that all of our classic games
get to live their best lives future here
we go
so there are two options like it was
four by three but then 16 by 10 was
added let's see if I won't mess with the
yeah okay yeah not my preferred way in
fact I think it drops the framerate a
little bit yeah it looks a little up
yeah but there it is for you I'm gonna
in a few open in a few seconds here I'll
switch it back to fourth
it looks good yeah for a second there
just stuttered oh yeah oh yeah Shayna
says how long have you been playing on
this stream approximately 8 minutes
yes I just tuned in in life yeah when
did this game come out anyone I'll have
to go up and around okay there are more
bad guys I missed the key Oh
whoa
yep honestly it's like these dudes have
a real coalition going right now for
those monsters they want to kill me dude
guy I like well you don't see it much
you only see him like the intro menu but
your little doom guy character he looks
so like skinny and he has a little space
helmet it's doom guy but apparently not
that skinny nope
all right let me switch it back to like
a little face on the bottom yeah look
around I can't I wish I could do that I
can do the right one like the rock all
right the left one doesn't go I can't do
that I always wish I could okay there we
go it seems a little smoother IMO now we
got the red key oh they're warping yeah
no problem Spencer I'm glad you got to
check it out we do have a little bit of
a delay on the stream so I'm sorry if it
took slightly longer than expected for
us to try out that feature if you guys
want to see any other features let us
know we'll try to test it out for you
after we play a couple of levels of this
SMO we're gonna try something to add on
yeah
final doom was added here's another
quick add-on they they implemented quick
select for your weapons keep it locked
on the Super Shot kind of like how it
still feels like it fits perfectly it
does it's all pixely like that's not how
it was in the original doom
you just press 1 through 7 and what
about yeah they managed to add something
new while still making it feel classic
and definitely oh and they added I
haven't tried it yet they added right
there on the bottom left and right quick
save and quick load let's try it out I'm
gonna click right to save right where I
am
before we end it we should find like a
death loop and quick save I was like
right before dying Phineas Lee oh I fell
down oh good thing I quit saved huh yes
a quick load
oh [ __ ] oh sorry get that light there we
go hey I was in the middle of reloading
and everything oh why didn't I remember
that it was one second ago cripes it's a
mess down there
alright pick up some health here we go
so dark trying to take them out using
the barrels cuz that's fun okay we got
the blue key Oh
oh yeah something else worth noting is
is this update free yes yeah oh those
lurking on the article and it's like
that's a ton of free stuff I know right
there like but yes so that's also worth
noting dude yeah okay Carlos this is
also available these these updates are
available for do one also yeah zoom one
had some more DLC also doing one and two
yeah this is just Ritchie's prefered of
the two we're gonna get into it but up
wow I goofed that up but final doom was
added so we'll play that a little bit
for sure
that's huge oh here's again this FAQ
section by the way is really good so the
question was what's the difference
between add-ons for doom and doom 2 and
they said we've made the final doom
add-ons the Plutonia experience and tnt
evolution available for both games but
that's an exception moving forward
add-ons will be released for either game
depending on what assets are required ok
so right now there's no real differences
but in the updates to come they will be
tailored specifically to each game
heck yeah pretty good I think this is a
good start right like improved quality
of life in both and then go for that
tailored experience a matter I thought
they'd be like done with any sort of
update after this but that's nice to
hear that more is on the way
yeah and like the new new doom is coming
out yeah I ternal oh let's play some
final doom yeah quit here so here's how
you activate once you've downloaded it
on your switch or whatever console
there's an add-on feature here we're
gonna play the Plutonia experiment you
just select it and then now apply it by
pressing B and now we have a new menu I
love that the confirmation sounds like a
gunshot yeah
all right you know I haven't played
final doom in years
let's do this okay I believe that's just
the first level ah there we go
there that's what I was waiting for
tunes dem tunes
um someone asked is this available on
Xbox I believe and yes if the update has
been released to all platforms and all
you know that carry Dingman doom - yes
no one's left out sergeants say Salem
this says what's the first thing you
notice about a person that's an
interesting question I think for me it's
like their eyes because I'm like a
little socially awkward in person and
like eye contact I noticed more so than
other things so I guess I do their head
you know some eye contact if I'm
especially if I'm gonna talk to them too
much I do in fact makes me like I start
looking at in other direction me too
yeah that's right I don't know why I
feel like I'm staring too long it's like
okay weird are you staring at right I'm
like let me be natural and you know look
at the floor oh there's the blue key but
I don't think
so easy to get yeah oh dang oh dang I'm
surrounded y'all we will use our
environment to our advantage
check yeah yeah now we got the bang bang
got him come on
so these final doom was consisted of two
episodes the one you saw me select in
the beginning here and they create final
doom but I believe these were like
fan-made and then officially sold later
on Oh some fan work if I remember
correctly Doom one got the expansion
sigil which is MIT which was made by one
of the developers of the original doom
like last year so they're old looking
levels but made by the same guys from oh
yeah more like what wall I was about to
say 2019 I was about saved living in the
past I am
we were playing Doom in 2020 this is
great Brandon says I look at their shoes
first because I'm a sneaker head that
would make me feel extra self-conscious
cuz I refuse to spend more than like $10
on my shoes I just can't
plus I think I walk up anyway so only
one part of my shoe gets worn out all
the time right on the heel like on the
outer corners me too I would duck I kick
my feet out like a bear or duck what's
happening but my shoes are telling me
all I need to know yeah I'm gonna get
that under control I also have a heavy
heel on my right foot so like I get
holes on the bottom of my yeah also I
think my left foot is a little bigger
like my feet are all [ __ ] up well
that's a thing I think I I think I heard
like your left side of your body is
slightly larger than your eyesight
because your heart or something like
that that could be totally false not
gonna lie but you know how the Internet
is yeah consume so much information and
it agrees with what I'm thinking so it's
definitely the truth
whoa all right you know what now is a
good time to try out the quick save
feature link I don't want to rely on
that cuz that's not very cool not very
do me but it's there you know you're
getting into doom for the first time and
things are a little rough this is for
you
okay I never figured out how to get the
blue key why did I come back here hello
aren't you the same people who played
evil within says Daniel yeah we are
those people we are indeed those people
that was really fun week we played which
due to some scheduling conflicts turn
into like it was a rough week
you know the ghosts came and haunted
those additional days okay I'm about to
die hmm
look at my face open a ball do you like
terrifying
I'm awaiting the Beast you're like that
was our help
oh dang oh dang
they're swole they are fit yikes
although it's very dangerous in close
quarters so I'm gonna stick to these
yeah I was having fun with this oh I'm
out of bullets back to the shotgun mmm
dude was all about like checking the
walls oops rockets very good I'm hearing
some monster breathing over there I hear
him okay there were more out there how
scared you know what let's utilize the
new quick save Vito oh yeah
that's either shooting me quick load
noise okay so we know they're behind you
right cuz they were shooting you in the
back
Oh once I get out here they're somewhere
up somewhere out there oh there they are
ah punks let's try to snipe them campers
yeah you can't burst Oh oops
Wow with it you play too much cod I do
downside what is this this is the
granddaddy man oh where where where's
that coming from
I'm coming for you oh it's that
staircase that I hated
remember those two guys are just rush
them down this wall is not not your
friend right now no there we go who was
that off no oh ones chillin oh oh I hate
that sound you hear that yes that's a
very specific enemy that brings other
enemies back to life no I need the
rocket cuz he takes a lot of hits I said
I need the rocket because it's various
oh man there's a whole whole room over
there oh cool zero game said he enjoyed
our guilt stream and then it made him
buy the game how do you like the game
didn't finishing him cuz we we never got
to finish it actually and I I did like
that game for studio yeah it was cute it
was oh wow that wasn't cute at all let
me see if I can hit hang back quick save
cuz I'm quick I'm screwed
how do I even begin dodging weird
Oh what platform is this this is on the
switch man yeah let's see all right
quick load although I was at like 8
health look this is a deadly cycle oh I
don't want to go this way
not yet let me clear out this room
because I know the area boom right sneak
up on them real quick I hate those guys
they're pretty weak but their bullets
travel the fastest okay never mind there
yeah we get all like what's that
who threw that paper ball let me look
over there oh that's where all that
damage is coming from right in one shot
idea he did there's no health around
here oh well this is this is doom you
can't complain if it kicks your ass he
just like yep that's doom here we go
how did I there we go I killed one of
them ha ha yes for mr. Camrys in the
chat who is asking for an update list
I had just linked one in the chat for
you so you can see the full list cuz we
did read over it briefly earlier but it
is literally such a long list that I
would hate to torture the chat again
with that what's up there's a link and
yeah check it out let me try to get that
without warping yeah noise let me quick
save here this is the new feature that
I'm gonna abuse oh yeah
should I warp I can't go yeah I'm there
warp this is final doom by the way oh
just warped me to the other side okay
that's funny I hate that sound that
guy's around here somewhere ah where'd
he go he was over here with me I don't
like I'm going away yeah get away okay
um got some bolts for this thing I don't
like this pathway homing Rockets damn
you do Jack Skellington guys gonna quick
load now I know where you're hiding ya
Punk
see I can't use a rocket cuz that'd be
too close um shotgun alright let's see
is there anyone else around oh there are
portals down there
[Music]
fine
we were prepared this time no no ah
still not prepared enough enough
yeah that's the sound he makes I'm
straight up you know just bones he
really ate a lot of shotty yeah don't
fool me sometimes they're like go get
this and then bad guys appear out of
know that jump scared you it kind of got
me to you I'm not gonna lie the bones
guy yeah the first time when he popped
up out of nowhere
those are in the new doom to the
revenant although I feel like over this
past year or so I've gotten better with
jump scares you have Slenderman ones
like at its peak Riley that's what
really set me up for success in life
that slender arrival game because now I
feel like okay please continue and
quickload like no problem they were just
waiting for you I know my help
he's campers campers here Slenderman was
fun though that was probably although
your hands hurt the next day because you
were I was trying to run so hard and so
fast that my hand was so sorry but I
mean it was cool I had fun even though
scared crap enemy huh oh no oh no I died
and got teleported Wow
there's a lot going on as soon as I pick
up that key oh boy yeah this definitely
um mmm got real intense real fast like
all of a sudden there were enemies in
every which way
yeah maybe yeah let's see this will
probably get me in some trouble but
let's see actually go one um Michael a
burger we're playing on the switch right
now actually and look smooth right oh
[Laughter]
okay wait behind me I knew a mouse out
of here no not out of here at all
are you serious yeah like this is a safe
space you turn my house get off my lawn
[Music]
Wow rookie I couldn't even you can you
know strafe in this game pretty well now
me oh man okay if you can dodge a wrench
you can dodge a fire I played five
nights at freddys it's pretty good I
think the reason why I don't get as
scared what that one is because it's
kind of like skill-based right like
you're really only gonna get jumpscared
bad if you lose right because they'd be
like I'm never played in here I've seen
them though it's all about timing and
stuff yeah yeah like I played it in VR
and then once I'm thinking of actually
like what I was supposed to do and like
closing the doors and managing
everything it wasn't as scary whereas I
feel like some of the other scary games
they're just like you know those jump
scares are activated based on which part
of the story you get to you know so it's
like inevitable you're gonna run into
those jump scares yep oh I'm letting
these two fight they can beat each other
out oh nice third party them exactly
save some ammo know what wall in here
quick save as a new feature well done
okay did we like our favorite new Beach
feel like a rookie using it but I
haven't played final doom in a long time
I played doom 2 a lot but final doom a
lot less so yes 9 asked this update is
for Steam as well correct it is for
every platform that Dhoom & Dhoom 2 is
available on even mobile so literally
every every version yeah if you still
have it for your calculator oh wow am I
gonna make a joke with that failed
this update yeah across all platforms
that answered my question no 8 it
immediately Persia are you at all
interested I'm gonna let you hold okay
cuz I believe in you
like I feel like I'm pretty good at
modern shooting games but old school
shooters I am so bad like the like
original Resident Evil's
that I am so bad I love that game the
aiming is just so it feels so foreign to
me yeah the controls are very old-school
and it made me realize like how spoiled
I am off of a day like shooting games
because it's just so different like even
now the way you're shooting no aiming
down so yeah yeah and you know for me
I'd be trying to like aim the gun up it
auto aim it auto-detects like their
placement on the map which is very nice
it makes it kind of easier but you can
still miss a shot really easily - okay
cleared this know what now's a good time
- quick safe I'm gonna do that okay I
was here and I there's the key although
there's two guys posted up right here I
do love me some left for dead I'm not
gonna lie I actually really loved that
that was a game that you know way back
in the day is to go to my little land
center of my friends we saw blaze and
left for dead
Carl says old games were made to take
your coins that's why that is a very
smart observation they're a very factual
observation yeah especially like
fighting games they just react to your
inputs like really sorry think oh gosh
yeah some when the arcade people would
set the cab to like the most heart the
hardest difficulty
no no thanks but they got your quarters
we have Street Fighter 2 here in the
office like we walk in the front doors
and I think it's set to the highest
difficulty I got the key either that or
I suck
engineers have play half-life we did
play half-life not too long ago yeah you
missed it hey nobody's available on yeah
we were happy about the Alex
announcement so we played some yeah
half-life okay what am I doing there I
got the red key so I can go back to this
area
I hate that noise where is he
we never found that guy I know he's
chillin somewhere hello Liz jeans how
you doin have Thursday hey thanks for
joining us
fiddles pass me it said whoa nice dodge
of that man keep his fireball
I saw that nope I was surprised I went
like all the way down this hallway and
missed his fireball Stephenson is no I
hate him
I need a rocket now right now you medium
Oh Annie's got a skeleton bro okay he
brought him back to life quit you in
there you can bring back anyone back to
life and I ran out of rockets - perfect
timing it's been a while there we go
that's for you chat so many die and
start all the way over oh oh why is it
blocked we just saved
we're actually just showing the benefits
of this add-on
okay we are that was for you that was a
demonstration for demonstration purposes
only
okay behind me something opens up that's
why what a me move very doom of you
you're forgiving you and he's like in
there with the hub chilling alright hey
wait wait I wanted to help all right
okay that one wasn't looking nice
I don't think this is citral no we're
playing doom 2 and sigil is available
today on doom 1 but we're playing final
doom on doom - yeah oh yeah oh I woke
him up there's more you know what all of
these monsters remind me of you know in
their original Men in Black where he's
doing the training stage and he like
they asked to like shoot aliens I'm
bored wait cut it yes yeah he's not
sneezing he's seen or he's not snarling
that he shoots the little like girls are
bored cut out
it's just hilarious because it was like
kind of factual I was like you're right
why she got those books that dudes back
no no he hurts you a lot yeah thank you
for tuning in yet we're playing doom 2
final deal these are these were extra
levels added made by I think made by
fans I believe ok there's nothing else
up here right I thought I saw a gun I
couldn't get whatever maybe you picked
it up already
maybe you know what I'm at 8 help digs
oh good see I can't get that one dang it
could have used those bullets wait no
more doors here isn't there there's a
map okay one way in one way out
yo that map that map is just like a grid
looks like the airport maps whoa okay
that door still freaks me out
any sound effect when you're really
logging by yeah anything at 8 percent
help okay I was already here that's the
beginning of the level this is a pretty
extensive level and since I don't
exactly remember the order it's taking
longer but it's all good there we go
I opened the red door yeah noise making
some progress just as I said that boss
is asking 60 FPS on switch question yeah
yes even undocked it's so cool yeah we
were just mentioning earlier that you
know this is a perfect summer let me
make sound effects that would be a
monster sound effect right there in that
monster will one touch kill you so yeah
bro P but really Goofy's hunting oh hey
I'm back here again okay good now that I
have the blue key I think I can go over
here okay ready for new monsters low end
games
piece o at games for a low-end PC hmm
hmm besides like obviously this one
which someone are you mission Jack I'll
do it Hey there we go the Mito a hundred
and nine wow that's an A+ I never get an
A+ in anything you know when people are
like a hundred reasons enough where we
were okay look no secrets though zero
percent items what the flim-flam
whatever more final doom that classic
soundtrack yeah heck yeah I know I can't
want to hear it work yeah turn it up a
little bit
let me turn down the sound effects cuz
they're so loud but I love it that way
but let's focus yeah and then we're
gonna turn up the music more yeah audio
just put the sound effects like one on
one there don't appreciate the tunes
yeah prioritizing the music for sure is
DFO still running cuz I remember they
took it the service sound and they
brought it back and I was super hyped
but you couldn't transfer your account
so I was kind of sad and then yeah that
was the last I saw of it but that's a
great game for PC that doesn't really
require much GFO dungeon Fighter Online
it was really fun it was really fun it
was also really oh yeah see that's why
we need sound effects oh that guy was
grumbling and groaning behind you we
didn't hear anything
turbo later yeah I gotta have it
[Music]
being all right I should be fine Oh let
me quick load ha
we're going down oh okay
I think the sound effect ratio is good
oh oh I hate those guys I need a mint
[Music]
you got this pistol just kidding I think
it's tough if I get close this is the
best gun but from far I can snipe them
off with this one this is a little
regular shotguns a little more
concentrated
[Music]
it's always tough they are pre puff
bones boys they're cornering up over
there though come on show yourself good
as I squirrel away
I just hate their tax because they're
homing rockets oh yeah hit him hit his
brother though
coming out oh no there was another guy
hiding I eat you see I had more guns I'm
gonna quick load again all right you got
this Ritchie I believe in you man thanks
me that
[Applause]
I'm still trying to think of like good
PC is that don't require much or like
for a low in peace oh I mean not gonna
lie League of Legends does not take much
to run like I download it on my work
laptop and it works okay now that I made
it down there I'm gonna do a quick save
and see what was making that noise skull
girls fighting games Oh like you know
what shotty
vs. Gatling gun 1v1 me ro come at me a
lot of dude games a lot of later
additions to doom games you have to
shoot stuff to like open secret doors
puzzle act some puzzle action yeah
context there is different aspect modes
here we kind of shut it off earlier a
little bit yeah this is our personal
preferred mode 360 nose go to my put
that on I'll show you
Oh King panda said that their laptop
can't well then maybe it's not as low so
if you're into widescreen 16 not 16 by 9
16 wider a little bit of that a debating
team right there
wait what I didn't do it
is it why but it doesn't go all the way
oh I thought it filled the borders no
well here it is 16 by 10 it's just a
little whiter why did I forget that I'm
not sure if it goes full full why it's
being on the other platforms or not sure
either but you know not every game looks
good and widescreen Oh phew hmm this is
where I died last time oh I don't know
we shall use it I think I'm do think hmm
okay they're fighting each other it
seems yeah that's helpful are we out of
rockets yeah I think so I'll check let
me quick load here ha ha not a family
GLaDOS that's totally fine it's
definitely not for everybody there's
someone there
hey you shooting gonna toes yeah you're
good there it is
let's see never really fought em okay no
I'm not full ammo with this and do I
have rockets no body either
[Laughter]
[Music]
enough do I want to go out there again
wait is that a button no is it really
the only way way up the staircase
we are currently playing on the Nintendo
switch that's the babe the armored thing
is a bait you like walk forward to get
it in the door close by date 101 but
although now I don't know which way to
go if I don't go that way let's check
out the map map map I'm moving along
with it I'm just trying to scroll up
okay so if I do drop down it looks like
gonna go to the right or the left
there's more okay so it's not it is bait
but I go out there and run I think I
will leave oh man take care of the goons
over there the disrespect okay okay man
guys when I play Minecraft all I do is
build stuff I don't actually play the
game with the monsters in it I put it on
that beginning it no they're like
apparently you know you fight monsters
I'm I'm like I just want to build stuff
yeah some of my favorite things to watch
are like Minecraft time-lapse videos
where they make whole cities and stuff
seem like the Starship Enterprise from
Star Trek like all of it like a massive
scale is amazing oh godö
that is literally one of one of my legit
life fear is being crushed you like that
yeah
that's awful that is just like what
that's terrifying to me I think that
began because I played a lot of Tomb
Raider growing up and there are a lot of
like squish - yeah same with me and
Sonic getting squished and Sonic is an
instant death all right let's try that
again any more bullets
no who a little potion I hate that guy
I'm just gonna run for my life Daniel
asked if the FPS dot WAV files are
available I'm sorry I'm a wrong person
to ask about mods and stuff like that I
don't know I'm gonna switch it back to
four three by the way there we go v10
yeah I like that little confirmation ok
yeah we're ready for them now wow wow oh
oh ding Baron of Hell Satan relax oh
it's ok I got the super shotgun viewer
these sheep
it's you can lighten up somebody whoa
throwing his boogers at me there it is
keep them germs to yourself all right
I'm not going there because we know what
happens even though there's a rocket as
bait
Kevin wait in the chat says hey how's it
going it's going well no Kevin playing
some doom to enjoying all the two
add-ons and hanging out with you guys
whoa oh I did have to go through their
muscle dudes yeah yeah these guys are
keeping their 20 to their hands or is it
just like little Finn their hands okay
chickens yeah they don't have any
projectiles which is great enough
okay I'm hearing the little skeleton
boys where are they probably upstairs oh
yeah oh my name isn't working I think
about to be on a high area is the door
it looked like there were different
lighting effects on that all right let
me back it up I can handle this
no reloading and you have got to love it
now for that gun anyway is this on pc
yes it is okay update has been pushed
live to you all platforms including
mobile cool I got the yellow King made
it out alive I think that deserves a
quick save but we're personally playing
on the switch yeah sorry your question
answered both oh man I think I have to
go back out that way
it's a dead end over there i shooting
each other yeah there's one guy over
there oh I got hit in the back with a
rocket ding not starting that over this
is another feature here the little quick
weapon select very nice
maybe this one okay I have to deal with
these guys behind me first they suck
yeah they're trying to flank you we're
just trying to live our best lives I
think I killed one of them I did I move
my head I think I did I do that all the
time it helps it does got him
okay well now what's the way over there
switch them engineer says the music is
making me depressed why what no to make
you happy stop F do I get there oh wow
all right here we go I'm gonna I'm gonna
quick save here see on the bottom right
there's a new feature we love it
here we go this is where it was prettier
yeah oh you're getting your toes shot
that's right okay I've been here I have
to figure out how to use this trail of
bodies left behind that's one thing you
would like no more like leaving you can
leave the depth like sprites there to
show you've been there it's cool okay
I've been cleared out this area yeah hey
I know it's time to die thank you
what was up here that date I think yeah
the bait shield was up here and I'm not
ready for that
nope I'm not ready for that I'm gonna
try to see if I can explore down here
and open up another secret door in this
hallway I did something oh boy
you know what's crazy was like these bad
guys are just chilling in these tiny
little rooms forever forever and ever
I don't ask ya engineer you don't have
to be older to please now's a great time
to it because it's probably the best
it's ever been with all these quality of
life updates perfect time to pick it up
and play y'all that's all I have to take
into consideration like back in the day
when the
these games came out it's not like
anyone playing like were other types of
like FPS players right so it's like
things like it was like that's fine they
kind of popularized the first-person
shooter so now you have some some skill
going into it already yeah it should be
easy
oh I have a yellow key wait your anthem
says what will be the game for community
Friday tomorrow
well well Brandon we've got treat for
you Monster Hunter Friday is returning
with Ben and John Luke our Monster
Hunter world i Spartan I believe has
some goodies for us so they're gonna be
playing I know a couple weeks ago you
were asking when that was returning and
it has come the time is here princess
sweet ain't it oh no I press the switch
and it did that like that's mean I went
through here early here yes I'm too
quick say hmm it looks like you can make
it through yeah but I've been through
that area before mm-hmm
well well hold on in fact I think that's
the only way out yeah I have to go
through there why did I pull the switch
they told me and maybe they're like hey
you have the yellow key you know what it
does activates me makes your life more
difficult
yeah great all right you got this
there's some space in the middle for you
too yeah don't look I know I switch over
here I can but it does nothing
chicken what what is our map say we
check you know yes that's gonna call you
can walk around whoops yeah I'm actually
uh works like live going up these stairs
I keep pressing the wrong button there
we go
all right let's try it again up here
[Music]
Thanks
more maze like that I remember there we
go yeah this just brings me back up
camera cane this looks cool yeah we were
here too
[Music]
and we're missing something we're
missing something
yeah I think something important here
that you'd some like puzzly thing I got
a shoot telling you yeah go back to this
room you shoot all the faces ready here
we go wow I just right over yeah we
never actually went in there because
they had all the built-in in there we
just the way I wish that were their name
all right
where can I use that red key at that
door we walked up to you we're like oh
I'm so surprised that worry I know
exactly what you mean though yeah I have
no waited that's right Ben
oh wait that was the door Preston just
in case that was the door right dang all
right before I die from anything rash in
a quick save now we can look around for
a red door at least we made some just
keep shooting this skull there's got to
be one of these skills there's gonna be
some important Ghost Writer chill bro we
got time for this hearing more to do are
they just continuously these funny
oh my goodness oh my hair get away
[Music]
here we go alright well I think I think
I was supposed to do that I think it
moves everything along a little bit
right yeah must be one of those you know
clear these out and then get high reward
aggressive I hate these guys
[Applause]
god
yeah gotta let them trickle in yeah I am
in control here
okay maybe something there you go I like
wait he behind me okay good
they're fighting each other okay yeah
you can see that more Oh
go strike these little brothers yeah the
whole family's here alright now that
that's done yeah all right let's check
the rest of these buttons that opened
that which I can't jump to keep pressing
yeah oh you know I bet you you're
supposed to open that and see that the
key was in there and be like no I gotta
go figure you're right this one's a
phony Hey okay well I think I've
explored this room that door also open
so this one no oh yeah that's where more
than bad guys huh in a quick save right
here
and see if there's anything I can do
about this area I don't want to be here
we gotta do it me I think we do know I'm
dead watch this
no falling damage fortunately everything
else killed yeah huh
so yeah that's pretty much the last
place we have to go however we are
hurtin yeah let me see if I can just
snipe everyone off with this all the
door closed I wasn't really like that
happened whoops yeah this one Strief at
a time and hope they never get oh man it
got you like right on the forehead it
did you have Rockets I'm just gonna
waste it on them this I've had enough
those bone boys yeah I mean when they're
off to the side like this Oh Swift one
to the max quick load quick load
oh yes Ritchie definitely after the chat
for that one that stunk so I think you
should start off how you did where
earlier where you're like on the right
and you just poked out a little bit so
that they will waste their fireball okay
and then when they walk to the center
where you can't use the wall as
protection take the rocket out okay what
do you think with this then or just with
the rocket start off with this use the
wall you know do all slow play at first
but try not to push them over to the
middle yet you know how you're barely
peeking and then they would look in fire
yeah
go back try to link drag out the amount
of time it takes them to walk directly
front of you that's it and then now it's
rocket time oh look over there you see
meatball wasn't on our side that time
people yeah last time meatballs on our
side okay we've made some more progress
that time it sucks I'm just so low at
health nothing around here huh I keep
saying that
accidentally all right
got the shield
yeah oh it's so sensitive
I goofed nobody so he's the other side
of the wall you slips oh yeah they're
like right in front of you it's like
hard to use a wall I'm gonna going
Rockets a-blazing yeah yeah just uh just
don't panic and panics you just yeah
right because I only have limited right
I've like the first run you were like ah
yeah it helped but yeah yeah okay
boom killed one yeah yeah we go have one
rocket for that to me thanks
whoa oh whoa
dodged it if that is our there to get
across the way there's a red button to
[Music]
that one behind me you got this I
believe are you sure I will try okay get
it get a feel for the buttons and stuff
purchases on mistakes we got this oh I
should have saved after I killed those
guys oh gosh
it's so sensitive it is and there's no
way to turn it down
feels like a mouse like for real like
vacuumed a great first attempt it's
funny now I know I have to stand still
oh shoot button r2 or you know except
that's okay it's the plus button and
then l1 it's a quick load yeah there you
go
okay okay yeah baby
got to you that's my thoughts exactly
doom is so gloriously hard it says that
Daedalus
yeah absolutely unforgiving but it's all
about trial and error oh god Jay come on
is all geez
yeah distracted us all right this is
this is the one yeah something
definitely stuff starts to happen after
you kill these guys that's the move
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm speedrunning the dyeing process
yeah just bring chat oh dang teleported
off someone hit you I think it was the
rocket I wish I had more help or just
save us
[Music]
you got this doing some double damage
there it's okay
getting the hang of it yeah
[Music]
yeah
come on email find your business hey
I'll do with you later your turns on the
way for real that little shield doesn't
do [ __ ] by the way the one well have you
picked it up maybe it'll help reduce
some damage because your health too low
it's okay we'll do it
this is where we need to be it's looking
like a whole minute to shoot at me just
unloaded you can hold it down and it'll
keep firing yeah thank you quick look 20
hi discovered oh oh whatever
I killed myself it's funny how I
discovered doom 1 & 2 back in 2004
couldn't run doom 3 ever lease on my dad
easy just play oh you couldn't pick up
doom 3 I released so your dad was like
just play one and two best advice ever
I love doom 1 & 2 way more than three
version you got it oh I was risky you
should
I suggest it's okay cuz we see that's
right quick load new feature we love it
okay I just can't let the homeboy over
there see me Thank You Rosie says if I
remember green armor only absorbs 25% of
damage and mega armor lock 70 another
meatball died no he's out there oh crap
hang out down here I'll hit you anyway
Wow tracks really well
[Music]
gotta stay hydrated got this burger the
that shotgun pushes them so far away you
try another weapon I think you have a
chain gun still that's probably yeah yes
yeah yeah thanks quicksave thank you
quick save you need to do update you do
best
alright here you see me yeah all right
thank you take the wheel
let's see what's up the floor is
poisoned by the way is it three where it
says of course but there are portals
down there there's no other there's no
other way to go then down so I'm gonna
try to shimmy quicksave Aryan I just did
up there wow I like how he waited though
we went through all that and then he was
like yeah keep you yeah poison you don't
take fall man oh they're green now they
were blue oh that post that came out
Brown yeah what did that do though let
me see if I can click them or something
or kill that guy with being a jerk being
a peeping tom yeah oh I'm just trying to
Center my shot and I'm failing miserably
oh my god really you can't even hit him
it looked like it poked up so I think I
can but I just have to get good it's so
bad they make it so sensitive excuse me
honestly I'm analog on the switch yeah I
usually use the pro controller when it
didn't work and so yeah you were saying
but yeah it's getting easy okay so yeah
there's the pillars I'm clicking them
- num-num hey guys my thing
listen over here
I want to be over there wait where is an
invisible bridge I'll walk through that
I just was gonna say this looks like a
footbridge or something hell yes who
said that in chat less huh
yes bless you great tantrum great
tantrum we love you you're always I was
like these posts have to mean something
yeah what does a little secret bridge Oh
what I closed the door that switch
closed the door and I know it there was
something here
wait no you know there wasn't here it
was just freaking out purrs I'm on edge
oh they killed one of these guys take a
walk of faith yeah okay this is the end
of level we right so close to but it's
all yeah we got them you want to try the
next level
no no I do not because I feel I died the
same amount of times you did within like
a 10-minute spend it's super sensitive
this music though I definitely feel like
I'm on a mission now
oh man they give you alerts I'm loading
up thank you good idea all right now I'm
scared what they're gonna throw me into
[Music]
no no I'm it the judge right enough
I'm using the wrong gun forget my said
of use something else
jeiza yeah or these hands these hands
alright let's place it press the button
in GTFO it's an elevator to lift fire my
yeah oh we found my mixtape here now yes
I'm sorry give me that I put on the
headphones and I just died no way I quit
jeez you know normally not a not a big
fan of that despite how much I'm using
it I try to that's where the stream sake
I mean we'll say that for sure but I am
I am enjoying using it this time but for
Doom it's like you know go big or go
home is that the ending no that's where
I came from
alright now I'm scared of any which way
I go
here that I opened something up I knew
there was a secret somewhere there's
thousands of secrets in this game Wow
another one oh no the most guilty boy
[Music]
Rockets be rockets whoa I almost went
out there yeah shotgun this one the
super shotgun mr. mixon your favorite
streaming music pod work oh why did I
just pick a fight with those guys they
won't even look at me
Neeta the tooted dude I'm screwed every
way which way I go okay I'm still alive
skeleton boy aka a revenant
skeleton boy more I have low health
should I be saving should I be quick
saving early oh it's like you never know
what's around the next corner so that
[Music]
drum fill the quicksaves optional is
pretty broken I'm not going to lie a
little too useful yeah I mean I love it
but it's perfect for stream because if
you die start all the way over Oh No
there was a lot going on out there see
the little spider guys Oh what happens a
fired meatball quick save and see would
you okay this puts me in a different
area of the same room you don't kill
these guys they keep shooting out the
little you know what me back up a little
bit re strategize huh right now that we
have a better idea what's out there
it's called strategy I'm milking this
thing for all it's worth
I want that meatball to come to me the
delivery yourself
Dora - yourself me - no no tip hey cool
is he gonna fight this fight urgh I know
where you go come back here
oh he goes at you that little guy needs
to mind his own business but he's too
far
[Music]
nope he didn't see me that time
[Music]
there you go I knew it the spider got
killed the skull I have three health oh
[Music]
dang it all right let me see if I can
cross this footbridge maybe being on the
other final okay is this an invisible
bridge yeah probably the worst of it oh
there's spiders on the other side Oh
booth with a capital F big oom let's try
to snipe those spiders in the rocket I
think I'm too far
so speed running
[Music]
that was a dumb move oh great these
hands okay
going across oh that scared me why am i
holding a pistol hello Mia what is that
welcome to the street happy Thursday
alright we're playing some doom - heck
yeah there was some fresh update wave a
bunch of stuff happened on doom - that
was a fail Rambo mode would you do for a
house type it out yeah well you know
what you did it last time are you
interested let me get shot here let the
quicksave gods be on my side I rush way
too much and I'm just all right got the
Rockets
okay so we have meatball and spider boys
up there Oh interesting okay over there
fighting you done
oh there you go nice got it all right
you know what I think I'm gonna yeah
imma start with this guy
actually this it's like Sly Cooper with
the random question where was Chris
during Resident Evil 2 he was gettin out
of town and making his way to the secret
European lab I think from Resident Evil
Veronica Veronica if I remember
correctly but you can't play him in the
extreme battle mode so but I think you
were the little blood splats ass Yeti as
when they blow up they spit out like
three of them I think
[Music]
you made I should have quit saved I
forgot
Oh after the it's fine I have a game
plan you could do it again yeah watch
out for the green networks hate those I
was like oh wow meatball and way over
there
[Music]
oh it's like Cooper if you play back my
Resident Evil to Chris Redfield thing if
you beat the campaign you get with the
DualShock version if you beat the
campaign you get extreme battle mode
it's basically like you know when you're
playing as hyung you can play with any
character and chris is one of them no no
not in the remake in the original Sly
Cooper
[Music]
is there another me know those things I
think just hang out think they were just
there oh wait on the top left I think
you're right I think there wasn't a
meatball hiding up there in that ledge
that spider how far can I walk there is
the meatball dude
oh this is a tough room man I get that
all right but I wasted too much animal
the first I hear we got here with all we
got
sly cooper you hyped me up he says well
I mean check it out if you have the
DualShock version of Resident Evil 2 I
don't know why we're talking about this
but he's there he's in the separate game
mode extreme battle this guy needs to
relax
anger management Lindsay says I got this
game yesterday perfect timing because
there was a boatload of updates and
we're playing one of them now we're
playing a final doom which is part of
doom - like it's a there are two Matt
packs that make up final news we're
playing it some hard stuff
[Music]
I love original doom Allah and I can
navigate it pretty well but the final
final doom I haven't played in a long
time Oh Brandon s Ritchie when are you
gonna pick play try SEC hero it's on the
docket dude I definitely want to
especially after playing it on stream
with David and I really got to like
actually see it for myself like you know
we've covered it a lot of scene trailers
but I never haven't had any hands on you
but after David played it it reminded me
of tenchu you know like I just wanted to
play it so it's on it's on the backlog
for sure tell me though how long is that
game cuz if it's shorter than most
people think I might get me sooner than
later this no joke I'm just randomly
[Music]
let's try their out chad is telling us
to see on the bridge but I don't know
you're surrounded completely while
dodging their attacks you need to be
quick
we're trying friends you know what
Persia
want to be super briny about it yeah all
right all right all right
we tried telling the Iraq neutrons
across the way there we go see now we're
close enough all right that knew me Bob
oh gosh
a lot there's a lot going on
Simon Says livestream Resident Evil 2
please oh my god I'd be a dream come
true I could die happy
luckily quick saves you did ok cool
oh no I accidentally saved right here oh
that happens you know what that's fine
we didn't we can level select if you
want to just scooch past this level
we're problem oh man I felt like I was
figuring it out oh man sad when sheets
go wrong right help I woulda said you
wanted to do start the level over ok
here we are
dang dang you know what I have an idea
now we can be grimy and cheat until we
get to that point what do you think yeah
I mean we only have 9 minutes left so
sweet god mode I'll do everything
options she's saved as dead every pretty
much like the story of my life
we have everything let's just go for it
we are invincible yeah the power what
the hell did I do already
mix it up this is my party we are
invincible jumps into a trench can't get
out no you
oh wow would it dork it will watch this
kill the Iraq noise Iraq no charms and
the Rockets first ya be surprisingly
close for the last would say 9 minutes
yes
let's get grimy give me everything and
and god mode alright now how do I
properly do this how did I start the
level before right here there we go
everyone out of my way great we have no
fear now excuse me
yeah oh you know what so paranoid
because of the Rockets do Splash Damage
not anymore oh whoops I bang the wall no
problem which way oh yeah don't mind me
one of those little flag thing one of
these good something not even close
Marik
[Music]
here's the BFG check this out
Wow I don't think so oh sweet revenge
lucky do you know that one you don't
have to even aim properly it's good I'm
just looking at the face I'm like man if
we do not have these settings right how
did we make it so far
now these are just like home you mean
nothing
[Music]
I think we're talking to somebody chat
great go straight I love the chat having
oh whoops
we are dead space that's on service oh
my god I am because this this floor is
supposed to kill me being grimy has
alright well let's see here
I think we have to go back to all we did
quicksave honestly maybe the cheats
meteos maybe huh man why did I save over
that oh I had done so well getting rid
of the first meatball
[Music]
hmm Ingram it's a bull hello outside how
are you thanks for joining us
alright we've got 18 rockets and a death
wish
try to get them oh boy it's too close to
use the rocket ok how about not god mode
but everything else yeah yeah at least
give us some guns yeah here we go
great because now we have 5 minute love
no time to play keep going through and I
don't mean oh here we go
oh no I forgot a hug God the first thing
plasma rifle is oh no I didn't even work
you know what I also need a quick save
I'm not doing that you want to try with
all the fun stuff yeah oh nice I'm gonna
get guns yeah and then what quick save
now great yes
you have every gun in every key noise
and maxed out armor and health
this bad boy Alex we are playing the
switch port today it runs at 60fps that
was part of the update even on the
switch thanks Brandon we'll see you
tomorrow
hey see you later get that account right
oh god oh oh yeah we need come in the
room all the way Oh horrible no alright
then we went up here oh he's fighting
somebody else break it up boys oh yeah
but it has like there we go he did we
play if you do that code again you'll
get ammo back this your first time live
no we uh Simon we we stream every day
every weekday from 11:00 a.m. to 12:30
p.m.
[Music]
got him oh yeah that's my bullets don't
[Music]
hate those guys love them and I hate him
they were so cool in a doom 2016 it was
nice to see him back I guess luckily
that's a quick sing all right yes I mean
thank you for joining us today
subscribe we're here every weekday for
some more gamespot live we play a little
bit of this a little bit of that this
room we're back quick save you're ready
to go wait
[Music]
see part deux butter where's me ball
he'll come to you but watch out for the
green birds
oh that was a good shot
[Music]
Oh dangle this is Plutonia we are
playing final doom and it was added to
the doom to port it's been so long since
I played this oh nice good great dodging
that's the creatures out a river
[Music]
this guy is so annoying
there he goes phew
back to the Rockets
[Music]
oh the ground is lava under your okay
it's very cool oh hey no this is not
Crash Bandicoot
oh no too close
meatballs making a flexible meatballs
not heartburn there's a lot of big oof
big goof we have any more of those
bullets oh that green The BFG come out
would be great in here oh he is spider
boy nice to meet you too Simon thanks
for joining us today hopefully you'll be
back tomorrow we uh we have community
Fridays where we play with the community
will be playing Monster Hunter I scorn
the new DLC so you're into that you can
you can watch or possibly join along I
just want that good gun yeah yeah we can
finally clear out this room you know
although we're supposed to wrap it up
right now I don't get half my room
because I'm acting
will this game port have some spaghetti
included in the box set yes absolutely
that was announced you will get
spaghetti no meatballs that's the offal
[Music]
all right you still landed a hit I'm
sure I can't wait for those little Oh
bro bro yes you got one
alright last you got this project
times a-tickin
[Music]
yep
BFG all the way that's right Oh who's
ready for June 20 Tony do an eternal
baby nice oh you got him
[Music]
oh there you go that was like what
all right I'm bad it's all good though
that room is impossible it was fun with
cheesy with more time I would got it
better get out all right you guys well
that is going to wrap it up for today's
stream thank you so so much for tuning
in and goofing around with us and
enjoying some do woman if you guys want
to try out all the new add-ons and all
the new goodies well you can just
download it the update for free to any
version that you have could solve able
to nin tomorrow for community Fridays
Ben and gentlemen we are going to be
playing some Monster Hunter and it's
gonna be a good time and of course every
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time you can
catch us right here until next time
we'll see you guys later
[Music]